>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Nancy Groce: My name is Nancy
Groce and I'm with the Library
of Congress and today we
have a very special guest,
David Bromberg.
And we're going to be talking
about the David Bromberg
American Violin Collection,
and specific fiddles and how you
came to acquire the collection
and maybe, what we
hope will happen
to the collection once it comes
here to the Library of Congress.
>> David Bromberg: Very good.
>> Nancy Groce: OK so, how did
you get into collecting violins,
let's just start
with the basics?
>> David Bromberg: Well,
I was a touring musician
and I played American
music and the first,
I had a very good fiddler in the
band, Jay Unger was in my band,
and I used to play
fiddle tunes on the guitar
and I decided I should try
and learn to play fiddle
because I knew how
I wanted to sound,
I wanted to sound just like Jay.
So, I was in Stockbridge,
Massachusetts
and there was a guy there who
had a wall full of violins
and I chose one and it turned
out to be an American one,
which seemed proper because
I play American music
and I have whatever
poisonous gene it is
that makes people collectors
and I started collecting
American violins.
At first, I didn't
know much about them,
but the more I did it,
the more I learned.
Eventually I went to
violin making school
and saw quite a few
beautiful violins
and knew better how
to organize things.
Because I wasn't
interested in amateur,
partly successful ventures,
and America has a lot of those.
>> Nancy Groce: You mean
people who do one violin or-- ?
>> David Bromberg: Yeah,
or have no training at all,
and really have only seen one
maybe German factory violin,
have a vague idea of what it
should it look like in the end,
and there are tons of
those in the United States.
And for a long time,
the American violin dealers
thought that's all there was
and if they saw something
good they would tell me, oh,
this isn't American, this
is German or this is French,
or you know, anything
but American.
>> Nancy Groce: And
that wasn't true?
>> David Bromberg:
No, it wasn't true.
Operating on the assumption
that Americans are not
genetically inferior
to Europeans, I couldn't see
why Americans couldn't have made
fine violins and the more
I learned about violins,
the more astounded I was
that people would show
me an American violin
and just dismiss it as not
being worth a gorgeous thing,
not being worth fixing
because it was American.
That's changed now.
>> Nancy Groce: So, how
many violins do you have now
in your collection?
>> David Bromberg: Um, 263,
but actually a few
more than that even.
>> Nancy Groce: And
these have been acquired
over how many years
of collecting?
>> David Bromberg: Oh,
it must be close to 50.
>> Nancy Groce: And is
this the largest collection
of American violins?
>> David Bromberg: It's the
largest and the only one
that I know of, of anything
approaching this size that is
of good violins and it
covers the length and breadth
of American violin making
from around 1848 to 1950.
And there is no equivalent
collection of French violins
in France or German
violins in Germany
or Italian violins in Italy.
There is nothing that
covers it like this.
Not that I have every single
one, but I'm pretty close.
Every single important
>> Nancy Groce: Now, you've
brought some examples of violins
to look at and I think in the
trade you called them fiddles,
is there a difference
between fiddles and violins?
>> David Bromberg: Well,
it's like a [inaudible] calls
his instrument his fiddle.
Vassar Clements, who
I used to play with,
one of the world's
greatest country fiddlers,
used to call his his violin,
so you go figure, I don't know.
>> Nancy Groce: OK, well
let's just start looking
at some that you brought in.
I think you brought
in, the unifying theme
of the ones you brought in today
to the Library of Congress is
that they all have some
relationship to Chicago,
and you lived in Chicago for
many years, is that right?
>> David Bromberg: Yes, I did.
This one, which I wanted to
talk about first, this was made
by a man named Herman Macklett,
and he was a German immigrant.
He settled in St. Paul where
he worked as an upholsterer
and he used to go
back and forth.
He was born in 1835 in
Hanover, Germany and I know
that because it was written on
the inside of another Macklett
that I owned, G-- and the rest
of the word was no longer
visible, but then Hanover 1835,
it had to have been [inaudible].
>> Nancy Groce: Born in 1835?
>> David Bromberg:
In Hanover, Germany.
And he was known
as the grandfather
of the first Carl Becker,
Carl Becker is very famous.
>> Nancy Groce: As
a violin maker?
A late violin maker.
>> David Bromberg:
As a violin maker.
But, Macklett himself
was a fine violin maker.
This is a beautiful violin
and a very healthy one.
Allegedly, most of his were
lost in the Chicago Fire.
I don't believe that actually
because I've seen more
than I expected to
see given that.
He was in St. Paul and he
traveled back and forth
between St. Paul and Chicago,
finally officially moving
to Chicago in 1868 and he died,
I'm sorry 1864, and
he died in 1884.
And people have speculated that
he must have seen French violins
and studied some really nice,
maybe a Vuillaume or something.
And I have a different theory.
>> Nancy Groce: Oh,
what's your theory?
>> David Bromberg: My theory
is that there were parts
of his life where we
don't know where he was
and I think he was either in New
York City or Astoria studying
with George Gemunder because
George Gemunder studied
with Vuillaume.
>> Nancy Groce: He's a
well-known violin dealer
and maker in New York.
>> David Bromberg: Yes,
and the significant thing
about George Gemunder as
opposed to the other members
of the family is he did work
for Vuillaume and there's a lot
of Vuillaume in his violins
and so I think that was
where Macklett developed
the French-ness in his-- .
>> Nancy Groce: So, you have
this direct line of master
to apprentice that you're
tracing down, that you can see
in people's instruments?
>> David Bromberg: Yeah,
generally speaking.
I brought one instrument
that I'll show you later,
by a self-taught maker,
or a maker that I
think was self-taught.
But this is Herman Macklett
and it's a lovely violin.
>> Nancy Groce: And
he had a shop,
after the first one
burned in the Chicago Fire.
And isn't there a story about
him and his wife putting violins
in rain sacs and carrying
them across the Chicago River.
>> David Bromberg:
Yeah, that's the story
that was passed down
in the family.
Carl Becker knew that story.
>> Nancy Groce: So, even
if it was one or two,
that's still a great story.
>> David Bromberg:
Well, he saved,
he must have saved
some very good violins.
This is a late one, I mean,
this one was made in 1879.
>> Nancy Groce: That's
a beautiful instrument,
it has a one piece back and,
yeah, very, very nicely done.
So, and it's still playing,
like a lot of the instruments
in your collection, it's
still in playing condition.
>> David Bromberg: Oh yes.
>> Nancy Groce: So, our next
Chicago violin is which one?
Which maker do you
want to feature next?
>> David Bromberg: This was
made by Johann Hornsteiner,
and in many ways Johann
Hornsteiner was the single most
important maker in Chicago.
He taught a generation of
violin makers in Chicago.
He was the head of the Lion
and Healy shop for a while,
and he worked in
different shops.
He had his own shop
for a while and-- .
>> Nancy Groce: And Lion
and Healy was a huge,
not only violins but all
sorts of musical instruments,
and they really supplied
a lot of America
and American orchestral
musicians for many,
many years, I believe.
>> David Bromberg: Yes,
and their violin
department was very important
and did business all
over the United States.
The ironic thing about
Johann Hornsteiner is
that there are very few of
his instruments, I'm sorry,
there's only this one that
we know of that still exists.
He did a lot of repairs
and he taught people,
but he was more enamored
of playing poker
than making violins.
And so, one of his
apprentices was a great maker,
named Frank Sindelar,
and most of the ones
with Johann Hornsteiner's label
were made by Frank Sindelar.
But this was made by
Johann Hornsteiner.
>> Nancy Groce: Now, there's a
Hornsteiner family, in think,
in Mittenwald, in Germany?
>> David Bromberg: There
is a Hornsteiner family
that goes back many generations
as violin makers back
to the 18th Century.
Actually, there was a
partnership between a maker
by the name of Neuner
and Hornsteiner
and they created a
factory in Mittenwald,
Germany called Neuner
and Hornsteiner
and it has its origins
in the 18th Century
up through the 1930's.
And, really the reinforcement
that this is Johann
Hornsteiner's,
if there was no label, and
there are labels in violins
that he didn't make,
is that this violin is
like the most beautiful Neuner
and Hornsteiner ever made.
There's an awful lot about it
that you can see those violins,
except it's so exquisitely done
and this was 1924 is
when this was made.
>> Nancy Groce: And,
what attracts you
when you're collecting
a violin like that?
Did you see it in a shop
window or did someone bring it
into your shop, or how
did you come by it?
>> David Bromberg: Well, I
attract American violins.
I gave a number of lectures to
each of the violin societies
and so when people run across
American violins, I get calls,
not only from people within
the trade but, you know,
other people are told,
well call Bromberg,
he knows about American.
And this came to
me from Jim Warren,
from whom I've learned a lot,
who has an important
shop in Chicago.
He's the third generation
and his son who's
in the shop is now
the fourth generation.
And when he got this he
called me because he knew
that I would be interested
and I was looking
for a Johann Hornsteiner.
There was only one other that
we know of that he made himself
and that was a Guarneri
model, this is a Strad model.
He made a Guarneri model for
Lou Wallace, who was a general
in the Civil War and
the author of Ben Hur.
And his estate is a museum,
but the curators know
of no violin there.
So, that one hopefully
will turn up someday.
>> Nancy Groce: So, when someone
walks in with a violin like that
and opens the case, is
it immediately obvious
that it's an interesting
instrument?
>> David Bromberg: To me?
It is to me yes.
>> Nancy Groce: And
what do you look for,
what do, how do you-- ?
>> David Bromberg: Well,
beauty is functional
and it takes a little education
to learn what constitutes
beauty,
but that's the first
thing I look for is,
does it look beautiful?
And the fine violins
are always beautiful.
Even the ugly ones are
beautiful in their own way.
>> Nancy Groce: That one
has a beautiful back,
can we just want to see that.
What's the wood on the back?
>> David Bromberg: Almost every
violin is made from maple back,
sides and neck and spruce top.
You occasionally will
find a cedar top,
but most are by far-- .
>> Nancy Groce: And would
that be American wood?
>> David Bromberg: This one does
not appear to be American wood,
but there are some species of, a
lot of American wood has streaks
that go across the flames.
And that's, then you know
you're looking at American wood,
but there are some species
that don't have that
and this never struck me
as being American
wood, but it could be.
>> Nancy Groce: So,
of all the years
that Johann Hornsteiner worked
and was influential in Chicago,
that's the one instrument we
know of his that still survives?
>> David Bromberg: Yeah.
I don't think there are many.
I don't think he start
to finish made very many.
But he did a lot
of restorations.
>> Nancy Groce: And poker.
>> David Bromberg: And poker.
Although he was a
great restorer,
he was not a very good expert.
Jim Warren's grandfather
told me a story
about how the concert master
of the Chicago Symphony came
in with his violin
for some adjustment
and Johann Hornsteiner was
the only one in the shop
and he looked at this
gentleman's Strad
and said it was a very
fine German violin,
which caused a bit of trouble.
No, people from France think,
tend to think, not all of them
but many of them, think that
the most beautiful violins must
be French.
And German makers think
they must be German.
[ Laughter ]
Hornsteiner, I already said that
he taught a whole generation
and amongst the people
who worked
under his tutelage was
the first Carl Becker, so,
that's where we'll go next.
>> Nancy Groce: OK, let's-- .
>> David Bromberg: To Carl
Becker, but not directly,
we're going to take
a little side trip.
>> Nancy Groce: Ok,
let's see another fiddle.
>> David Bromberg: OK.
>> Nancy Groce: You have
another Chicago violin here,
can you tell me about that one?
>> David Bromberg: This was made
by a man named William T. Lane,
who was born in England,
probably London,
and came to the United
States and had a violin shop.
He also worked in Lyon and
Healy under Johann Hornsteiner.
Before that I suspect he
might have been self-taught.
And he liked ivory
and he would put ivory
on different instruments
in different places.
This one has it at the corners.
>> Nancy Groce: That's unusual.
>> David Bromberg:
It is very unusual.
Nice wood.
Probably American wood.
>> Nancy Groce: How do you
know it's American wood?
>> David Bromberg:
See the streaks.
>> Nancy Groce: Oh, that
go across the flame.
>> David Bromberg: Yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: Oh, interesting.
>> David Bromberg: In the 19th
Century the French used almost
exclusively American wood
because they believed it
was the best sounding.
So, it wasn't just
Americans who used them.
But, this is Lane, and I forgot
that there's another
important piece having to do
with Lane that I should show.
I have a photograph of Carl
Becker at the age of 14.
>> Nancy Groce: The
well-known violin,
Chicago violin maker,
Carl Becker?
>> David Bromberg: It's
very important violin maker,
and he studied with Lane before
he went to Lion and Healy.
Now Lane was at Lion and Healy
and studied with Hornsteiner,
and later Carl Becker also
went to Lion and Healy
and worked under Hornsteiner.
>> Nancy Groce: This is
like a lot of other trades,
where people all know
each other and especially
since it's a master
apprenticeship trade,
there must be a lot
of connections among
American violin makers?
>> David Bromberg: Strangely,
there are not very many schools
of violin making in the United
States that I can perceive.
Really, the most identifiable
school of violin making was
in Chicago and the fountain
head is Johann Hornsteiner.
But, the immigrants
like George Gemunder
in New York had very
little influence as far
as I can detect in other makers.
But Hornsteiner, you
can see it clearly.
>> Nancy Groce: And
it's wonderful
that you've collected examples
from throughout the
Chicago school
so you can make these
connections
with your collection.
>> David Bromberg: Yeah, some
of Hornsteiner's disciples went
to Michigan and to other places,
but you can see an awful lot
of him in many Chicago
instruments.
>> Nancy Groce: Now,
did you acquire
that instrument in Chicago.
>> David Bromberg: Yes, I got
this when I was in Chicago.
Which brings up something
interesting,
I put together this collection
when I was a touring musician.
Otherwise I never
could have done it
because strangely enough,
American violins don't
seem to travel much.
There were five makers whose
work can be found anywhere
in the United States because
they were made for firms
that sold all over
the United States.
Carl Becker is one of them.
But, I don't know that you
would find a W. T. Lane violin
anywhere but Chicago.
>> Nancy Groce: And
how did you acquire it?
>> David Bromberg: Well,
I was living in Chicago
but I acquired the collection
because I was a traveling
musician and I would look
for violins wherever I went.
>> Nancy Groce: Do
you play them?
Do you try playing them
before you buy them or-- ?
>> David Bromberg:
You generally can't.
When you find an old violin
it's rarely in condition
to be played, unless it's been
in a shop and all fixed up,
and I discovered when
I visit violin shops,
when I started my collection,
that they had no respect
for any American violins,
"Oh there's one in the back,
this guy wasn't to bad but it's
not worth my while to fix it,"
you know, and then they'd bring
out something that needed a lot
of work that might be gorgeous.
>> Nancy Groce: Now you were at
a violin making school where?
And for how long?
>> David Bromberg: In Chicago.
I graduated.
That's what brought
me to Chicago.
I graduated from the Chicago
School of Violin Making.
>> Nancy Groce: So, you
were a touring musician,
just found violin
making so fascinating
that you just decided
to try it yourself?
>> David Bromberg: It's a
little more complicated.
As a touring musician
I started my collection
and collected American violins
and around 1970 I got burnt out.
I was working too much.
>> Nancy Groce: You were
doing very well as a musician.
>> David Bromberg: At that
time, I was doing well.
But I stopped completely because
I discovered I wasn't doing
anything a musician does
when I wasn't traveling.
I wasn't writing, I wasn't
practicing, I wasn't playing
with other musicians, so,
if I wasn't on the road.
And I didn't want to
be one of these guys
who does a bitter imitation
of something he used to love.
So, I decided to find something
else that I would enjoy
and devote my life to.
And I was interested in violins,
so I went to violin
making school.
>> Nancy Groce: And how long
did you study violin making?
>> David Bromberg: I was at
the school for four years,
to complete a 3-1/2-year
program.
>> Nancy Groce: But
it's very rigorous.
>> David Bromberg: It should
be very rigorous if you really,
really apply yourself.
Other people did much
better at it than I did,
but my interest really
was never in making,
I never wanted to be a maker.
I wanted to understand how you
could look at a violin and tell
who made it, when and where.
And you can't go by
the labels inside
because they're frequently
false.
They're occasionally right,
especially on the important
violins, that's wonderful.
But, you can make a lot of
money by putting the label
of a great maker in a violin
that wasn't by that maker.
>> Nancy Groce: And most people
wouldn't know the difference?
>> David Bromberg: Well,
they identify the
violins by the labels.
The experts don't do that.
So, I wanted to become
an expert.
So, I wanted to be able
to identify violins.
>> Nancy Groce: And
you really did.
You established this shop,
in dealing with, as they say,
high end fiddles,
for very many years.
>> David Bromberg: I'll be a
beginner until the day I die
because like music,
there's no bottom to this
and no one will ever
know it all.
People consult me
on American violins,
although American
violins are my hobby,
my business is European
violins with one
or two Americans thrown in.
This is a photograph of Carl
Becker at the age of 14.
That was the year he
made his first violin,
when he was 14-years-old.
And I think that this may
have been taken in the shop
of W. T. Lane, which
was the first place
that he got any tutelage.
>> Nancy Groce: He started
his training with Lane.
>> David Bromberg: Yeah, he
started his training with Lane.
>> Nancy Groce: Do you
know what year that is?
>> David Bromberg: Yes,
I think it would be 1901.
>> Nancy Groce: That is
such a terrific photograph.
>> David Bromberg:
Yeah, it's wonderful.
I have two Becker violins.
>> Nancy Groce: Oh, can
we take a look at them?
Made by this man probably
a little later in his life.
>> David Bromberg:
Made by Carl Becker.
Yes, one of them not much later.
>> Nancy Groce: Let's
have a look at them.
>> David Bromberg: OK.
>> Nancy Groce: So, you have
two lovely violins here from,
made by Carl Becker in Chicago.
>> David Bromberg: Carl G.
Becker, the first Carl Becker.
>> Nancy Groce: Oh, right.
>> David Bromberg: I was lucky
enough to know Carl F, his son,
who was a great maker also.
He was born in 1887 and
made his first violin
in 1901 at the age of 14.
>> Nancy Groce: And that was
the photograph that you brought?
>> David Bromberg:
That's the photograph
that I showed you, yeah.
And this one, he made at the
age of 20, so it would be 1917.
And this is a copy
of a Guarnerius.
And it's a beautiful violin
and it has the gorgeous
orange Becker varnish.
Becker worked for Johann
Hornsteiner at Lion and Healy
but he did the bulk of his work
later as he developed into,
well even now you can
see he was brilliant.
He worked for William
Lewis and Sons after that,
for quite a long time until
William Lewis was sold.
And he was the head of
the William Lewis shop.
>> Nancy Groce: So, he was
active the 1940's or the 1950's?
>> David Bromberg:
He was, I'm sorry,
dates are my, I will have to-- .
>> Nancy Groce: No, that's
OK, but he was a significant,
we'll do it this way, but
he was a significant force
for many decades in the
Chicago musical scene.
>> David Bromberg: I think
he was, let me check this,
I think he was active
until the 70's.
>> Nancy Groce: Really?
>> David Bromberg: I
may be wrong, 50's?
He died, no I was
right, he died in 1975.
>> Nancy Groce: So, he was,
so Carl G. Becker
was making violins
from about 1900 to the 1970's.
>> David Bromberg: Yes.
>> Nancy Groce: That's
very impressive.
>> David Bromberg: Through
to 1975, 1901 to 1975.
And he was also a great
restorer and an excellent expert
at violin identification.
So, this one is 1917.
And this is a Stradivarius
model from 1933.
>> Nancy Groce: And the
other one is a Guarnerius.
>> David Bromberg: The
other is a Guarnerius copy,
copy of a Guarnerius.
>> Nancy Groce: And experts like
yourself can tell immediately
by the shape of the violin which
standard model is being echoed
by a contemporary maker?
>> David Bromberg:
Yeah, if one is, yeah.
You can generally tell
first by the outline
and second by everything else.
>> Nancy Groce: Yeah,
that's why you're an expert,
it's immediately
obvious, isn't it?
>> David Bromberg: Well,
Strad's and Guarneri's are easy.
It can get harder.
>> Nancy Groce: Tell me
about the scroll on that one,
that one has a lovely scroll.
>> David Bromberg:
Yes, Carl Becker didn't
like carving scrolls
and his main competition
in Chicago was Carl George and
they used to accuse each other
of using German parts
and they were both right.
Occasionally Carl Becker
would use a German scroll.
Later on, when his son
became his partner,
his son would do just
gorgeous scrolls.
But, I wouldn't want to say
for sure who made this scroll,
it might have been Carl
or he might have modified
an import for the scroll.
Scroll doesn't have a great deal
to do with the sound and that's
where he was preoccupied.
In Mercure, France,
which is a town
that at one time was
almost completely devoted
to violin making.
They didn't consider the scroll
part of making the violin.
There was, in the 20th Century,
there was a guy named
Joseph Delenyon [phonetic]
who would make all the scrolls
and he'd go from shop to shop
and the shop owner would
peek out the window and pick
out the ones he wanted.
So, it's not an unusual thing.
In the time when this, in the
time when this violin was made,
catalogs from the violin shops,
the big violin shops would
also sell violin wood,
they'd sell back wood, top
wood, rib wood and scrolls.
They didn't sell scroll wood.
>> Nancy Groce: Interesting.
Now, during the early
20's, well three quarters
of the 20th Century, if
you were a performer,
say with the Chicago Symphony,
you'd go to Carl Becker
to buy new instruments
or just take care
of your existing
instruments, is that right?
>> David Bromberg: Yes.
Carl was very important to
the musicians of Chicago.
>> Nancy Groce: Did
you ever meet him?
>> David Bromberg: The senior?
>> Nancy Groce: Yeah.
>> David Bromberg: No, he
died before I went to Chicago.
>> Nancy Groce: But
you knew the son.
>> David Bromberg: I
knew his son and grandson
and granddaughter, a couple
of his granddaughters.
Grandson and one
of the granddaughters
are violin makers.
>> Nancy Groce: Still,
to this day?
>> David Bromberg: Yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: So, it's
at least three generations.
Was Becker-- ?
>> David Bromberg: Four, well
five if you count Macklett,
and then there was a
generation in between
when there was no maker,
so you've got Macklett,
a generation with no
maker, Carl, oh four, OK,
math is not my strong point.
There was something
that I wanted
to tell you and I got lost.
>> Nancy Groce: Did
his son have stories.
What would be a story
that his son would tell
about Carl Senior?
>> David Bromberg: Carl Junior
had a great deal of respect
for his father and his father
taught him identification
as well as making, and they
used to go to Lake Pickerel,
Wisconsin to concentrate
on making.
Although in later years,
Carl F. Becker, the son,
would go to Pickerel to make,
but he'd always bring along
repairs and spent a lot
of time doing repair as well.
>> Nancy Groce: So, just
to get out of Chicago,
they'd go to a quieter place
and concentrate on their art.
>> David Bromberg: Yeah.
There can be a lot of
competitions in one city
and sometimes the different
shops don't get along.
But, one shop about
which I, Carl Becker,
Carl G. Becker wasn't very
close to, once told me
that if you couldn't
get a Stradivarius Cello
or a Montagnana Cello,
don't bother
with anything other
than a Becker.
>> Nancy Groce: That's
quite a compliment,
especially from the competition.
>> David Bromberg: Yes.
>> Nancy Groce: Let's look
at another violin here.
Who made this one?
>> David Bromberg:
This violin was made
by Carl George in
Chicago in 1903.
He was born in the late 19th
Century in eastern Europe
and moved at the age of four
with his family to Toronto.
And at the same time there was
a maker named Franz Wagner,
a friend of the family and he
moved also to Toronto and then
when Carl George moved to
Chicago, Franz Wagner moved
as well and they
had a partnership
for a while, Wagner and George.
So, he was probably
taught by Franz Wagner.
He is one of the makers who,
although they weren't born
on this continent, learned
violin making on this continent.
He was here since
the age of four.
The Becker's were born here,
Macklett was born in Germany
and Lane was born in England.
Did I show anything else?
>> Nancy Groce: No,
I think that's it.
So, most of the violins in your
collection were made by people
who were trained in America?
>> David Bromberg:
It's hard to say.
There is a proportion that
were trained in America
and there's a proportion
that were born in American
and there's some that were
born and trained in Europe,
but even in those you find
some interesting signs
that they were made in America.
For example, the French makers,
there are a number of oddities
about the French makers
in the United States.
For one thing, the
French makers didn't stay.
The Italians, the Germans, the
Scandinavians, the English,
they'd come here
and they would stay.
The French couldn't
find a decent baguette
and they would go home.
So, you have some very important
makers in the 19th Century
who came to the United
States from France.
In the 19th Century it made
sense to get out of dodge,
because the violin business
was completely dominated
by J. B. Vuillaume in Paris.
So, and in England, usually
they'd go from Paris to London
and London was dominated
by the hills,
so some of them would
come to the United States.
Claude Murmol [phonetic]
came to the United States,
Paul Byee [phonetic] came
to the United States.
I have a Paul Byee [phonetic]
and a Murmol [phonetic]
in the collection.
I did exhibit the collection
in Paris at one point,
it was much smaller then.
They have a festival called
Musicora and at that time it was
in the Grande [inaudible]
and the French makers were
very anxious to see the work
of the French makers in America
because the violins would
be wholly their work,
no assistants.
They couldn't afford to bring
their assistants all the way
from France.
So, the Paul Byee [phonetic]
violin I have has a scroll
that's very different than
the Paul Byee's [phonetic]
that were made in
London or Paris.
>> Nancy Groce: And you think
that was his work
alone rather than-- ?
>> David Bromberg: I think
with the Murmol [phonetic]
the scroll is his work alone.
With the Byee [phonetic],
he might have bought it
from somebody, there's something
very naive about the scroll
on the Paul Byee [phonetic]
and he might have bought it
from an American maker.
That one's a puzzle.
>> Nancy Groce: It's like a
mystery when you get a violin,
especially when there's
no label on it or even
if there is a label, to kind
of suss out where it came from
and who might have made it.
>> David Bromberg: That's
true, and I was presented
with a violin a few weeks
ago, gorgeous violin,
and the color threw me.
I'd never seen an
American violin that color.
>> Nancy Groce: You mean
the color of the varnish?
>> David Bromberg: The color
of the varnish, it just really,
it distracted me and made it
very difficult for me to think
of who made something
of this color?
It's actually this color.
I don't believe in polishing.
But, I do believe in cleaning
and when I cleaned this before
bringing it here I found a color
that was pretty similar to
one of that mystery violin.
And there were some other
characteristics that matched
so I want to get the two
together in the same room.
>> Nancy Groce: Let's talk
a little bit now about,
what would you like
to see happen
with your American
violin collection?
>> David Bromberg: I think it's
very important to have a place
where you can verify the
identity of a violin.
Even American violins are
being misrepresented today.
I don't know of anybody
who is doing the kind
of things that [inaudible] did.
There may be people like that.
But I do know that there are
people who look at a violin
and say, what was it, what
is it and what will it be?
>> Nancy Groce: Sort of a
research library of violins.
>> David Bromberg: Exactly,
because there are people in some
of the auctions, you can find
violins with Italian labels
that were made on
this continent.
>> Nancy Groce: So, there's no
place you can go now to get a,
there's no museum or library
that has a collection of violins
that are sort of
encyclopedic of American makers?
>> David Bromberg: Right.
And to me the collection
is a document
and it's an important document.
But, it's also, it also
illustrates the quality
of American violins.
As I said, there was a
long-standing prejudice
against things made here, it
had to be, if it was going
to be good, it had
to be from Europe.
And I used to run into players
who had American violins and,
"This is my second violin,
and you know, it sounds good."
You know, they're, it
was like a talking dog.
It didn't matter what
it said, it was just-- .
But, they do sound
good, you know,
the best made ones are
wonderful sounding things.
As I told you with the Becker's,
you know, the preference
for a Becker cello over
everything except a Montagnana
and a Strad, and there was a,
the chief, the principal cellist
of the Chicago Symphony was a
gentleman named Frank Miller,
until he died some years
ago, who always played
on a violin made in New York
City by a man named Paul Pilat.
And he could have had anything,
could have had a Strad,
could have had a Montagnana,
but he loved the Pilat.
>> Nancy Groce: Now, are
some of the instruments
in your collection playable.
>> David Bromberg: Yeah, quite
a few of them are playable.
Everything I brought here is.
>> Nancy Groce: So-- .
>> David Bromberg: So,
they can be played, yeah,
and not every single
one is set up.
There are quite a few that are
not, but you know, you can play
on them and see what they do.
>> Nancy Groce: So, would
it be, let me start again.
So, if your collection were to
come someplace like the Library
of Congress, many of the
instruments could be used
or played or made
to speak again.
>> David Bromberg:
There's no reason why not.
Yeah, as I said, many of
them can be played today,
so that's kind of a given.
They could be loaned out, they
could be used in concerts,
there are any number of
ways they can be used.
But for me, because of my
own interest, the importance
of them is to see,
to have evidence.
This was made by this person.
>> Nancy Groce: A
reference library of violins?
>> David Bromberg: Yeah.
There's a violin
auction in Boston,
the Skinner violin auction, and
there's an unusual custom there.
Violin wholesalers take
rooms right across the street
from the auction house and
the violin dealers who come
to the auction, some of them
are not attracted so much
by the auction, but by
visiting the rooms of the people
who are there to sell
their violins and I used
to bring a room full of violins
up when I was wholesaling
violins,
as did many of my
colleagues, and there's a lot
that goes on in those rooms.
>> Nancy Groce: You
mean trading or-- .
>> David Bromberg: Trading,
buying, selling, identification.
>> Nancy Groce: Just passing
information back and forth?
>> David Bromberg: Yeah.
I mean, it's a busman's holiday.
>> Nancy Groce: Fascinating
world because there's just
so much to know about violins.
>> David Bromberg:
It's something,
some people buy violins
over the internet,
which has always struck
me as buying a shoe
with no size specified,
off the internet
and a very fuzzy
photo, you know.
>> Nancy Groce: Do you have,
in your collection
of 263, more or less.
>> David Bromberg: No,
there's actually a couple more
that I didn't put any specific
value on, that are part
of the collection that will
come here with any luck.
>> Nancy Groce: I know
it's like asking you
to name a favorite child,
but do you have a couple
that are your favorites?
>> David Bromberg: This
is one of my favorites.
>> Nancy Groce: And why,
this is the Carl George?
>> David Bromberg: This
is the Carl George.
I think it's a beautiful violin.
I think he did a fantastic
job on this instrument
and I don't know
what else to say.
I think this is a great violin.
>> Nancy Groce: It
appeals to you?
>> David Bromberg:
Yeah, it speaks to me.
There are a few others.
>> Nancy Groce: So, tell
me about that violin.
>> David Bromberg: This
violin was made by Carl George
for his sweetheart in 1904 and
in that year, the photograph
of Paganini's cannon, that's
what he called his violin,
appeared in the Chicago
newspaper
and Carl George copied
from the photograph.
>> Nancy Groce: Because
the original cannon,
which is a very famous
violin in Genoa.
>> David Bromberg: The
cannon lives in Genoa
and very rarely has it ever
left since Paganini's death.
>> Nancy Groce: What
makes a violin beautiful?
>> David Bromberg: Everything
about the way it's made.
I mean the first thing that
most people see is the wood.
The first thing the violin
experts see is the outline,
the silhouette.
And the precision
with which it's made,
the quality of the wood and
the varnish are important,
but also every aspect of
the making, the arching,
the cleanness of the
execution of the purfling.
It's three strips of wood that
are inlaid around the violin.
The purpose of this
wood, of the purfling,
is to make the top weaker there
so that it if it's struck,
the crack will go as far
as the purfling and stop.
For this reason, there are
some Italian and English makers
who didn't purfle the back,
because the back is
much stronger wood.
But, the truth is that
violins look a little strange
without it.
>> Nancy Groce: And
what about sound,
can you determine how a violin
will sound by just looking
at it, or do you
have to play it?
>> David Bromberg: A violin
maker should be able to tell
if he can make a
violin sound good.
If the violin is beautiful
and the three-dimensional
arch is beautiful
and the varnish allows it to
vibrate, then you should be able
to make it, then it's your
responsibility to make it sound.
And I don't like altering
the thicknesses of the top
and the back, but there
are people who do that.
I find that the importance of
the ribs is sometimes ignored.
>> Nancy Groce: The
ribs are the sides?
>> David Bromberg: The sides.
How can you expect the
top and back to vibrate
if the sides are rigid?
It can't. And so,
I've had great success
with occasionally bringing
out the sound of an instrument
by bringing the ribs to
the proper thickness.
But, you know, you also
have to do the right set up,
you have to have the
proper angle of the neck
and elevation here and here.
>> Nancy Groce: Yeah, and
there's some inside parts
to the violin right that
need to be adjusted.
>> David Bromberg: Well,
there's a base bar along the,
that supports the base
and that's very important
to the sound, and
the fit and position
of the sound post is important.
>> Nancy Groce: Which is
the little post that goes
to the back to the front.
>> David Bromberg: The
wonderful and horrible things
about violins is that everything
counts, absolutely everything.
This distance is extremely
important to the sound.
>> Nancy Groce: Between the
bridge and the tailpiece.
>> David Bromberg: Yes.
The position of the tail
gut is really important.
How close together
they are or far apart.
You can do marvelous things
that way and in our shop,
we are very slow to
move a sound post
because you can do an awful lot
with the lightest
tap on the bridge.
Moving the sound post is
generally a bigger change
and you don't need
big changes to make
to a big change in the sound.
>> Nancy Groce: Can you
talk to me for just a minute
about American varnishes?
>> David Bromberg: Well,
varnish is a mysterious topic.
Every couple of years someone
discovers the original varnish
and they publicize
it and therefore,
their violins are the ones you
should buy, but the truth is,
we have a lot of
different varnish recipes
and I think the original
varnish has been rediscovered
many times.
The problem is, nobody
can prove it.
Stradivarius, you know,
all this nonsense is made
about Stradivarius' varnish,
when it was exactly the same
as the varnish that was
used by everyone else
in his town, it had to be.
Stradivarius was a member of
the Instrument Makers Guild
and the first law
of every guild is
that you must patronize
the other guild members
of the different guilds.
So, Stradivarius by law
had to buy his varnish
from the apothecary as did every
other violin maker in town,
and they bought the same thing.
And one of the clues to this
for me was the violinist
of J. B. Guadagnini who worked
in four or five different cities
and his varnish was different
in every city he went to.
Because the apothecaries used
slightly different recipes
in every city and
there you have it.
>> Nancy Groce: And what
about American varnishes.
>> David Bromberg: There's
a cornucopia of them.
I think it's very difficult to
identify an instrument's country
of origin by the varnish because
some makers used a different
formula of varnish on
every violin they made.
So, the prescription for
varnish can be anything anywhere
in the world.
>> Nancy Groce: OK.
Thank you very much.
Oh, two questions, OK.
>> David, did you or
Nancy did you ask him
where the American's would
have gotten their wood source?
And David, do you have
any violins that you made?
>> Nancy Groce: So, do you
have any violins that you made?
>> David Bromberg: Do
I have to admit it?
>> Nancy Groce: Oh, yeah sure.
>> David Bromberg: I
have a couple, yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: And
do you play them?
>> David Bromberg: No.
There is one that I used
to play occasionally.
OK, I have the, I don't
know what to call it.
I'm the only person
I've every heard
of who played Carnegie Hall
with his own violin three times,
three different violins.
So, there you go.
>> Nancy Groce: So,
all of them now can be,
you can say were
played in Carnegie Hall.
>> David Bromberg: I guess so.
I don't know where any but
the first one is now, so.
Oh yeah, I know where
two of them are.
The third one I have no idea.
>> Nancy Groce: And are they
part of your collection?
>> David Bromberg: Only one.
>> Nancy Groce: And you
consider that your best violin?
>> David Bromberg: Oh
no, that's my first.
>> Nancy Groce: Let me
ask you another question.
Can you talk a little bit
about where the American violin
makers got their wood from?
>> David Bromberg: Well, it
depends in what period of time.
In the, there were violin makers
early in the 19th Century,
there was a man named John
Antes in northern Pennsylvania
and there were others, and
they made their violins
with locally precured woods.
As America became wealthier,
we imported more violins
and there were more
people making them
and we also imported
violin making wood.
And as I mentioned, the
shops through the 19th
and early 20th Century would
sell violin makers tools
and back wood, side wood,
top wood and scrolls.
But, in the 19th Century,
American wood became a fashion.
During the 19th Century,
many violin makers
in the United States, I'm
thinking particularly in Boston,
became, and New England
in general,
became really preoccupied
with obtaining the
oldest wood they could
and I have a violin I believe by
Calvin Baker, on which he wrote
on the label that the wood was
from a famous church dated
17 something or other.
Now, modern, there's
a modern science
of wood called dendrochronology.
We can tell the age of the most
recent ring by comparing it
with [inaudible] samples, it's
a like a huge database of wood
from the primary places
from where wood comes,
and we've discovered that
the great makes of Cremona
in the 18th Century very
rarely used wood older
than five years old and
almost never older than 10.
So, you know, the
whole preoccupation
with old wood doesn't
seem to hold much water.
>> Nancy Groce: So, the wood
that supposedly had been aged,
doesn't make much
difference in the sound?
>> David Bromberg: Well,
it might because
age does something,
but we don't know exactly what
and where and the great makers
in Cremona, being members of
the guild, had to buy wood
from the wood cutters guild.
I mean, there are
all these stories
about the Stradivarius going
into a forest at midnight
and tapping the trees,
complete nonsense.
He had to buy it
from the same people
that every other instrument
maker in his town bought it from
and the only unique thing,
these wood cutters would
have a special shed
for instrument making
wood and the unique thing
about this shed is
that the floor
of the shed would
be lattice work
and they would throw old
vegetables underneath the wood
so the wood would be fumed
by the ammonia fumes,
they would be ammonia
fumed by the-- .
>> Nancy Groce: By
rotting vegetables?
>> David Bromberg: By
rotting vegetables.
How much this had to do
with anything is really a
serious question because none
of the wood that was exposed
to these fumes would end
up on the instrument.
You'd have to carve
away all the outsides
and so the fuming would
have to go pretty deep
and whether it does or
not, I couldn't tell you.
>> Nancy Groce: And what
about using historic wood,
like from an old church
or a famous tree or,
do you have some examples
of that in your collection?
>> David Bromberg: Yes, as I
said, I have at least one violin
where it's written
either in the violin
or on the label sometimes, you
know, the wood from this was
from such and such a church,
constructed in 17 something.
Wood, every few years
or so, someone will come
out with the secret of
Stradivari and then reveal
that the Stradivari's
and the Anandi's
and the Guarneri's are
going to be useless soon
because they've reached the
end of their usefulness.
You know, wood can only
last so long and you know,
there are houses in Europe built
in the 14th Century out of wood
that are still quite healthy,
so I don't think that's
even close to true.
>> Nancy Groce: OK, thank
you so much for coming in
and sharing information about
these wonderful violins.
>> David Bromberg:
Thank you for having me.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.